you got to describe the first date you
met her there but what was your first
real date yeah it was fast I what
happened was you know we had that we
were doing this World War two picture
and it was it had it had a lot of World
War two music and there was the
possibility we might dance and Goldie's
a professional dancer yeah so I said if
we do have to do this I said we need to
practice this a little bit and I said I
could try to find a like a swing band
somewhere here in town and she said yeah
why don't you do that that's a good idea
so I found it and the only place that
had a swing band at that time was the
Playboy Club I said I got a place you
know and so we went there and we just we
never danced we just had like two and a
half hours of this great time talking
yeah and that we just both look at each
other and said that the night we're not
ready to call this off yet so we went
anyway we ended up going to a house that
she was renovating and had to break into
the house because it was locked off I
was locked off just for construction
yeah so we were you know looking at the
imaginary rooms with the imaginary
furniture and found ourselves upstairs
in the imaginary bedroom and no I'm
going in house yeah and now we're having
real sex right and
you're being so delicate about it you
know and then of course think took their
turn and then we had sex yeah I know
there's a light shining on us and it was
the cops we're pointing life and we were
both like she said easy guys it's I own
the house since to my house it's okay
and I kind of looked at us I said why
don't you get a hotel room the cops got
a report of people having sex and we
gotta get in there and break it out
you